hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the world blitz championship
it's the ending everyone requested for
and it is what the chess world deserves
after him calls him one little game
against holidays after oh sure everyone
said it would be a shame if Magnus just
wins the tournament straight away but
Magnus drew his last two games
he drew against he drew against
Alexander II shook in the penultimate
round and then in the final round
Carlson drew against you Yong GE and
Hikaru was able to defeat two of his
opponents Alexandra Zubov and in the
final round he defeated Ralph Mamedov
catching up to Magnus so both of them
with 16 and a half points now go into
tiebreaks two of the blitz games are
about to be played and if they are drawn
then they go into Armageddon so first
our first game Nakamura had the white
pieces across and went for the Berlin
defense and that game ended in a draw
but it was it was a it was a it was a it
was an insane game for a three minute
game really and and the Berlin defence
surely was across since World Chess
Championship preparation and in the end
Nakamura was able to draw and this is a
Game two of their match of their
tiebreaks match so without further ado
with the white pieces cross and opens
with d4 now we have Knight to f6 Knight
to f3 we have d5 and again Bishop to f4
Magnus goes for the London system if
it's good enough to take down Vladimir
Kramnik
why not use it against that he Cora
Nakamura
we have c5 Nakamura goes for the same
line as Kramnik with III East 6 and the
knight B to d2 Bishop to d6 offering a
trade of dark square the ship's Magnus
captures captures captures and now to
take Nakamura out of the book D captures
on c5 only one game in the database has
this move so why not use it against he
car in a in a three minute game with
Queen captures on c5 and now c4 there is
one given the data base the one we're
talking about wer Knight the c6 was
played but here we have D captures on c4
and this is a new move so already as a
move 8 we have a completely new game so
Magnus continues to develop while
developing pieces Bishop captures and c4
we have room
castles by Hikaru and rook the c1l
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries Queen back to e7 by Nakamura
and now Magnus just castles with b6
preparing to fianchetto the bishop here
to this beautiful diagonal with Quinta
ytube a preparing the trader of will
Bishop to a6 Bishop the b7 and now rook
F 2 d1 so putting in both rooks and the
open files and Nakamura still has to
finish his development Knight bt7 and
now Bishop to a6 going after this light
square bishop nakamura forces the trade
with knife to c5 and here Magna straits
Bishop characteris Queen captures now
the Queen occupies the diagonal and
Knight the e5 by Magnus an excellent
square for the knight and the Hikaru of
course immediately wants to kick it away
night C to d7 and now comes a very
important moment in the game at Magnus
place Queen to f3 he offers a queen
trade because the Queen on b7 is
undefended you have to either trade or
move the Queen and Nakamura does not
want to play this position against
Magnus it's an equal equal position one
thing that's different is that black has
this beep on pushed so the c6 square is
a bit weekend but Nakamura does not see
this interesting at all to play against
Magnus
so Queen to a6 goes after the a to pawn
and here Magnus goes Knight to c6 and
it's an incredible square for the knight
even at the price of the a to pawn
because it covers all of the squares the
Nakamura can used to activate his rook
so you cannot go to c8 because of 97
trick picking up the rook so here you
could to go for a queen captures an a8
but first Nakamura wants to get rid of
this Knight to e7 idea
so King to a trade first and now Knight
to c4 by Magnus now Magnus will put the
other knights to d6 and then Magnus will
have two monster Knights something you
don't see very often so Queen captures
an 82 by Nakamura and now before going
for this d6 outpost first g4 Magnus
wants to kick away the knife from f6 and
then go Knight to d6 and then put some
pressure on f7 is both the knight and
the Queen will control f7
so here h6 doesn't really do anything
for you because just g5 and you
cannot capture if you capture Queen h2
rechecking g8 and the night east 7 is
mate so not not possible so after G for
Nakamoto goes knife to c5 clears the D D
7 square for the other night and first
Knight to d6 and now Carlson's monster
Knights control all of the squares and
it is impossible to activate the rooks
and here Nakamoto goes for Knight the b3
and Vladimir Kramnik joined the
commentary with Peter like oh and he
called this move a desperado move and
nakamura played with rook to c2 getting
the rock out of the way and now Quinta a
4 with a double attack on the pawn here
but also threatening some discoveries to
expose the rook so Magnus just kicks it
away yeah we look the c4 and now Queen
to a6 and now if you look at the
position the two rooks are undeveloped
the knight is well not doing all that
much here the Queen on a6 not really
participating in the game
Magnus pushes g5 and here there are
problems after the knight moves the f7
pawn becomes weak Nakamura has to make a
move and that the time is sticking he
played Knight to d7
but now Magnus shifts his attention to
the King side rook to h4 here we have
Nightbeat the c5 getting the knight back
into the game but this doesn't work feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning move for Magnus while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to get to
congratulations if you if you've ever
seen this mate you know it's a mate in
three rock chapters on h7 check King
captures queen h5 check King goes back
and now Knight to e7 is made so this is
how the game should end but Magnus
misses this remarkable but even even
Magnus can means this under under such
immense pressure if he wins this he has
all the three titles World Classic
champion rapid champion and blitz
champion something he achieved only once
in 2014 that's you know that pretty much
works it works only when you talk about
Magnus since it's very unlikely that
someone else will achieve something like
that but okay you know you have to try
Knight captures on f7 instead Magnus
goes for material rook captures on f7
and now you have to capture it if you
don't capture
if King J then this is again mate 97
checkmate
so rook captures on f7 and now Queen
captures on f7 grabbing that grabbing
that material and now well if you do
nothing 97 followed by Knight to g6 is
made so you have to play something Queen
to e 2 was played by nakamura went for
the rook here but just rook captures on
d7 by Magnus with Knight captures on d7
and now Queen captures on d7 so now
Magnus is up a piece but we've already
seen that Nakamura is perfectly able to
to draw a draw game at being a piece
down like he did against what Emir
Kramnik so look the f8 going after the
f2 pawn but now Magnus place the only
move that wins for white which is rook
to f4 just blocks in this rook and now
this red is rook captures and if you
trade then captures captures and well
Magnus is just up a knight and well he's
a lot up on time so nakamura will not
try and hold magnus to a draw well being
a piece down although this didn't happen
after work to f4 nakamura resigned and
magnus wins the world blitz championship
as well so there you have it that's
that's what a perfect warrior looks like
the winning the world class the
championship winning the world rapid
championship and winning the world blitz
championship something that magnus
achieved twice already in 2014 and now
in 2019 and we just i mean incredible
stuff but it was it was much better that
they had to go into tie breaks because
of what happened with with Ferrara this
way and Nakamura had had the chance to
take magnets down and well it was just
the first game he tried but Magnus
Magnusson Berlin defense is just too
solid and he even got a lot of active
play from it and now here again the
London system system prevails and it's
hard to say will it will it become like
super popular because here Magnus just
took down Nakamura and Vladimir Kramnik
and a lot of other people with it which
is just insane if you ask anyone they
will tell you London system is it's
trash you know why it doesn't have
anything out of the opening but it is
just comfortable to play and if you're
as good as Magnus you know you can do
anything you want with it so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and my
short coverage of the world rapid M
blitz championship I will go through all
of your hashtag suggestions and check
out some other games that we we missed
and here are the standings after 21
rounds of the world blitz championship
so here they are
let me just improve that a little bit
okay there we go
so magnus carlsen first with 16 and a
half points he karo tied also with 16
and a half
but in Thai breaks he lost so Nakamura
is second and third place Vladimir
Kramnik so the guy comes out of
retirement to have some fun at the world
blitz championship and takes first place
that's how strong what Amir Kramnik is
fourth Alexander Grisha with 14 tied
with maxime beaugeois grab all so with
four 14 then with 13 and a half we have
a lot of people all areas of Raja who
got 6th place that loss against Magnus
really shook him but here you can really
see how stronger Larisa is he won 2nd
place in the in the world rapid
championship and sick here sixth in the
world blitz championship by completely
pretty much the only one aside from the
meter and rating at really crushed
Magnus and yeah forgot to mention Magnus
only lost one game in both events to
Dmitry under 18 then Vladislav Artemyev
in 7 you youngji maxima clock of young
christophe Duda the military of the
under-18 Vladimir fellow serve an issue
here in Alexander's above 11 Armenian
Evancho ernesto anarchy of Peter Svidler
Boris Gelfand also boorish the ageless
we have even cheaper in of those are
with 13 and a half and then with 13 the
drive elects a young pony she who really
was there on top but then in the few
final rounds it went bad for him a rough
mama dog saw excellent and Maximus you
guys those are the top 25 players as you
can see all all grandmasters sir now
like I said I do hope you enjoyed the
short coverage I would like to thank a
Gleb cop chunk of Josef Matt Sierra
Hamid mizuchi at a certain parties and
Kai on our tour force for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions maybe taking a day off and
then we are probably about to start
big saga so thank you all I will see
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day